c'est une vidéo parodie publié le 3
avril sur les réseaux qui a mis le feu
aux poudres indigné tout le maroc l
affaire commence le 4 avril dans un café
à marrakech c'est en quelques heures et
bien la polémique va exploser celle de
brahim bouhlel connu pour son rôle dans
la série à succès valider et de deux de
ses amis
l'affluence up bar booking et l'acteur
eddie bush n'est pas dans une vidéo de
deux minutes les trois garçons ont
proféré des propos insultants envers les
femmes et des enfants présents juste à
côté d'eux seneca encore 15 9 du coup
j'ai eu 6 15 et ressemble à moi ou
menacez face à la polémique grandissante
brahim avait décidé de présenter ses
excuses
je souhaite avant toute chose présenter
mes plus sincères excuses au peuple
marocain des excuses qui n'ont pas suffi
puisque aujourd'hui la justice a rendu
son verdict et l'humoriste a été
condamné à huit mois de prison ferme
pour diffusion d'une vidéo d'une
personne sans son consentement et
détournement de mineure une décision que
son avocat maître morel déplore qu'il
est avec nous ce soir pour réagir à
cette condamnation
merci maître morel d'être là on va dire
maître morel 1 et non pas jean-jacques
parce que c'est pas du tout votre coeur
et donc c'est charles passait beaucoup
mieux d'ailleurs
merci d'être avec nous alors déjà qui
ait brahim boullane alors brahim
boullane c'est vraiment la star montante
du cinéma en ce moment en france ce qui
l'a fait connaître du grand public c'est
sa prestation dans la série validé sur
canal+ qui est un énorme carton regarder
un petit extrait pas une boule lcc qui
est un mec qui t'a donné un petit coup
de pouce ppi petit coup de pouce quoi
comme ça c'est ces masses ta logique
je suis fort je t'avoue que moi j'ai
trop peu de temps à consacrer aux autres
je suis que sur ma musique ma carré
voilà c'est bien du répondant c'est bien
rappaz dans son volet la bonne attitude
basse car il est là
ils entendront faire une bouffe charisme
ballon on va revoir la vidéo polémique
en version vous allez voir toute la
vidéo aux ados comme ça on pourra vous
faire une idée
début avril brahim bouhlel publie une
vidéo dans laquelle on le voit dans un
restaurant à marrakech
aux côtés de deux amis et il est en
tournage de de valider à ce moment là m
non il est en vacances ils d'accord il
juste en bas grave parce qu'il va
retourner la saison 2 banide et il a
déjà trois îles 4 avril dernier quand
même offert canal est bon les diffuser
ou pas oui les fans on va voir on
diffuse voir là je sens que ça va être
un petit peu la diffuser non je crois
que ça va être un petit peu retardée
alors un bon derrière donc derrière
cette vidéo vous allez voir c'est un
déferlement
il a fait une parodie dans quêtes
exclusives regardez vous allez nous dire
ce que vous en pensez
ouais bien la personne qui m'a parlé
qu'est ce que je fais quelque sorte il
ya ce droit-là et des pas fait on dira
mais la mairie et toute l'équipe
laissant dire et je vous passe quelqu'un
d'autre vous connaissez super bien salut
c'est beau mais c'est nicky encore 15 9
du coup j'ai eu six gosses et vous savez
quoi
essence huile terrain moi parce qu'il
est je suis pas parti chercher à l'école
jaurès ouais merci mais ça tu sais j'ai
l'habitude et décroche un peu partout
dans tout le code mc est ce que dieu me
pardonne mais un jour je fais tous les
réunir
regardez moi ça ressemble à moi oui
semble assurée intègre aussi sympa même
comme son père aller fiscaux on va le
faire alors après ça après cette vidéo
c'est un déferlement et au maroc que ça
passe pas du tout du tout du tout
bernard montiel caisse alors je vais
vous dire parce que en plus moi je
travaille et j'ai travaillé très bon
temps avec les ces associations qui
éduque un peu les enfants des rues y en
a beaucoup on le sait par tous paco
marocain à la dans le monde entier alors
justement m'envoyer un petit bout je
voudrais vous le lire parce qu'il est
extrêmement intéressant ces faits ont
choqué bien au delà du maroc il s'agit
d'atteinte grave à démineur qui ont été
utilisés à des fins dégradantes charme
être assez pour vous que je dis tout ça
pénalement il s'agit de détournement des
mineurs
la tête à la personne jour public il
s'agit d'une insulte aux femmes et aux
femmes marocaines en particulier ce qui
est scandaleux évidemment le maroc est
un pays souverain avec une justice
indépendante et souveraine
et comme on demande à toute personne de
respecter la loi française quand on est
en france on respecte la loi marocaine
cantonné au maroc et sur ces faits la
loi marocaine est similaire la loi
française de nombreuses associations de
protection de l'enfance et des droits
des femmes se sont mobilisés tant la
diffusion de la vidéo était très
importante
au delà des frontières du maran alors
bahreïn bull elle a présenté ses excuses
ensuite sur les réseaux sociaux le 5
avril dernier
il demandait pardon au peuple marocain
explique qu'au contraire sa vidéo était
partagée dans le but de combattre les
clichés justement regarde plus je
souhaite avant toute chose présenter mes
plus sincères excuses au peuple marocain
ma volonté n'était autre que deux
justement me moquer des gens qui
véhiculent ces clichés
j'ai essayé d'être drôle je reconnais
que je me suis totalement planté
j'aime profondément ce pays et ses
habitants je pense chaque jour du temps
avec les enfants qui apparaît sur cette
vidéo
ce soir je suis complètement effondré en
prenant conscience du mal que j'ai fait
je comprends à quel point mes propos
sont graves et c'est pour ça que je vous
demande sincèrement pardon
voilà et derrière donc brahim bouhlel va
être incarcéré c'est vrai que cette
histoire tout le monde en a parlé c'est
juste incroyable alors maître morel
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui lui est
reproché
qu'est ce qui est bien ce sont les voilà
des accusations contre lui alors ils
sont les chaînes les chefs de prévention
un peu évolué pour ce que j'en comprends
c'est que on a reproché la diffusion
d'une vidéo sans le consentement de
personnes ces personnes est en
l'occurrence des mineurs même s'ils sont
floutés vous avez évoqué détournement de
mineure c'est effectivement je n'étais
pas planté sur la vidéo qui semble qui
semble avoir été la seule à avoir été
retenu mais nous nous contestons
absolument
la qualification ou la matérialité des
faits mais n'est pas pour nous
constituer voilà là ce sont les chefs de
prévention qui ont justifié aux yeux du
tribunal de première instance de
marrakech la peine qui a été prononcée
contre brahim et contre ses amis je
précise que je suis en charge de
coordonner la défense de brahim et de
sami parce que même si brahim et le plus
densifiées amis qui partagent le même
sort rien sur dix y est ré pénitentiaire
mais il ya plein de gens qui se disent
comment on peut passer d'une vidéo
instagram à la prison huit mois de
prison ferme
là vous me confirmez qu'il dort en
prison depuis deux semaines
oui il était en détention provisoire
jusqu'à hier et maintenant comment s'est
passée l'interpellation comment ça se
passe donc j'ai pas j'ai pas les détails
mais c'est la vie d'une nation il sera
interpellé convaincant ce qu'il faut
savoir d'abord c'est qu'il n'a pas
l'initiative la diffusion de la vidéo
vous avez vu vous l'avez dit on a là une
tentative manifestement raté de faire
une caricature d'une émission vous avez
dit cette enquête et kuzi policiers raté
coûte une émission sensationnaliste même
lui en convient c'est raté
et bien sûr la situation on apporte
marocain c'est vrai qu'ils auraient été
blessés par cette vidéo tirée que la
vidéo ait raté ça il a dit on à l'effet
démultiplicateur main instantanée des
réseaux sociaux une interprétation qui
est qui et en premier degré passionnel
sans aucun sans aucun contrôle aucune
coupe décontextualisation et donc les
choses s'enflamme il ya beaucoup de pays
pas que le maroc où tout comme les
choses s'enflamme ensuite il ya une une
réponse policière et judiciaire et donc
on a quelqu'un qui était l'idée plainte
contre lui il ya des gens qui ont porté
plainte là au départ la famille
des enfants a porté plainte d'accord se
sont ils se sont vus l'emballement
autour de la vidéo et se sont ils ont
porté plainte
c'est pas quelle est la motivation pour
l'ont fait je ne suis pas juge mais en
tout cas ils ont porté plainte et ils se
sont désistés ce qu'on appelle le thé
nadu d'accord ils ont existé ce qui
normalement devait éclaircir l'horizon
judiciaire de prime et sami ça n'a pas
été le cas alors la loi marocaine elle
dit quoi sur ce sur ce dérapage
alors ils disent que je viens de vous
dire c'est à dire de cesser ces délits
sont punis de un à trois ans de
détention et de 2001 et délits qui
semblait commencer quoi dénigrement non
c'est bien mais il faut savoir que les
ions d'une vidéo vivement de la personne
c'est sa détermination il faut savoir
qu'en droit de la loi française
oui il faut savoir qu'en droit français
parce qu'on parle de la loi on va la
liberté d'expression on doit peut-être
l'évoqué c'est un fait important y
compris d'en faire un usage imbéciles
mais il y à la loi de 280 n'épuise pas
la question
c'est cette diffusion d'une vidéo ça
existe en droit français c'est également
puni en théorie d'une peine de prison
la seule de la différence c'est que
l'incarcération de bris mais c'est bien
en france est inenvisageable nature
voilà par rapport à ce qui a été
ce qui est ce qui a été vu dans cette
vidéo comme henri revel des systèmes
judiciaires ils sont différents il ya il
a été condamné
comment il a vécu ça de condamnations
qu'est-ce qui de manière évidemment il
était il est sous le choc il est
traumatisé je vous dis ils s'attendaient
à une telle condamnation pas du tout pas
du tout mais alors pas du tout et il
était dans une situation joyeuse en
vacances avec des amis dans un pays
qu'il adore avec d'excellentes relations
avec tous les marocains et marocaines
je tiens parce que l'aspect humain est
quand même très important on a voit ça
et on est choqué il faut dire que cette
vidéo dans la compréhension qui en effet
au premier degré et radicalement
contraires à tous qu'il est lui même
d'accord lui et sami c'est à dire c'est
quelqu'un qui est je vous le dis parce
qu'on a eu des attestations et les
réactions puisque je les ai de piquage
sa perte creusée
comment toutes ces attestations tout ça
ça pas pesé lourd du pas pour l'instant
d'accord manifestement il est
jovial généreux il prend soin des autres
il est toujours en soutien quand il voit
quelqu'un dans l'empathie dans la
compassion il a été bénévole d'une
association d'aidé aux orphelins au
maghreb
il est pour les entourage professionnel
il est professionnel ponctuelle il
apprend tous ces textes il est toujours
voilà il fait l'unanimité c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a pris la grosse tête
précisément qu'est ce que c'est la
situation des familles c'est pareil il a
le ce même profil
c'est pas un influenceur comme on l'a
dit c'est quelqu'un qui est qui et dans
la musique le rap d'accord un dénicheur
de talent qui fait participer et c est
lui aussi à trois mois il a visité un
orphelinat
je ne pense pas qu'il ait prémédité la
situation qu'il qu'il subit aujourd'hui
comme ça on est même que le ch donne un
supplément pardon non si vous avez 2002
minutes on passe à d'un attaquant depuis
et ont vraiment rien dit règlement on
nous a demandés vraiment il veut
vraiment maître morel veut vraiment
voilà être en témoin aujourd'hui non
mais ça fait pas débat là dessus merci
oui il faut que j'aie le temps
effectivement compte tenu de la
sensibilité de deux dossiers de
peut-être d'exprimer des choses c'est
important de comprendre ça pour
comprendre la sincérité des excuses de
prime quand il s'excuse
c'est non seulement parce qu'évidemment
il est dans cette situation dont il
comprend qu'elle est en réalité menaçant
ceux qui ne quittent qui ne percevait
pas mais aussi parce qu'il est il est
touché d'avoir blessé parce qu'il
comprend que l'interprétation qui est
faite
voilà ce qu'est ce que vous dites aux
gens qui disent il s'est excusé parce
qu'il a vu que ça devenait très
dangereux pour lui mais s'est excusé
pour vous parce que il a blessé des gens
non c'est pas la seule motivation
évidemment qu'il l'a fait aussi la
pression qui pesait pour lui parce qu'il
a compris que ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que lui donc c'est un comédien et
humoriste passionnés d
le procès des comics consistant à
incarner un personnage vulgaire et
cynique je veux dire il y avait des
salles en tiennent en entière avec
coluche qui jouer
un policier raciste et alcoolique sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est pas tout non
bien sûr c'est ce qui fait toute la
différence
oui oui bien sûr ou la chine
oui mais marrakech du rire réussi de ce
type d'humour je leur jeu leurs gardes
c'est un procédé comic con qu utilisent
tous les poulets sauf que là il ya une
incompréhension totale
c'est totalement raté donc qu'il ya
cette interprétation mais je pense qu'il
est important quand même qu'on se
conçoit on voit quelle était l'intention
qui était de dénoncer précisément ce que
lorsque qu'on lui impute comme un fou en
tant qu'avocat au kilo kick auxquels ils
adhéraient vont en tant qu'avocat vous
avez été choqué par cette lourde peine
huit mois de prison ferme alors toutous
ont été choqués leur entourage
évidemment d'un point de vue c'est pour
moi je suis pas je veux dire je ne suis
pas dans le bon rôle à la place où je
suis né pas de commenter la décision du
année de faire en sorte d'obtenir le
plus rapidement possible la libération
de bram i et sam il ya une demande de
mise en liberté qui est faite lundi
prochain l'appel a été fait aujourd'hui
ça sera jugé dans trois semaines un mois
on verra après les questions et
éventuellement de la détention si jamais
s'est maintenue voilà quelques années
mon rôle
le maroc est un pays souverain il est
son système judiciaire off comme le
nôtre un degré d'appel
donc on va aussi faire en sorte de
recadrer les choses d'avoir plus
attestation de d'éléments de
contextualisations moi je suis pas ici
est donc un commentaire serait
maintenant de ma part pour tenter de
faire pression sur le sur la nationale
jusqu'à ce que j'ai entendu alors cette
histoire on en entend parler je vous le
dis depuis des jours et des jours je
vous dis même moi on m'a appelé je vous
dis on a appelé tous ne m'a appelé aussi
pour essayer de jeu puis juin le roi du
maroc pour lui demander voilà si nous on
est est à terre si on pouvait faire
quelque chose voilà c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai rencontré deux fois extrêmement
sympathique mais moi j'ai dit j'ai je
vois là je ne peux pas intervenir là
dessus c'est qu'ils ont demandé à plein
de comique français aussi d'intervenir
des gens qui le connaissaient est ce que
des gens qui ont essayé d'intervenir au
plus haut sommet c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
et qu'apparemment est vraiment ça
passait pas pour l'instant la justice
c'est d'abord ce qu'ils ont en tout cas
ça ne savais pas ça mais ce n'est pas ma
démarche d'accord voilà et moi je sais
que c'est pas votre démarche ne
m'intéresse pas
pas forcément de brahim et tout ça qui
essayait de voies de fait l'idée c'est
que je coordonne la défense ne manquez
pas des initiatives malheureuses de peau
de propos vous imaginez bien que ya
aussi des journalistes qui s'intéressent
je suis venu ici avec l'idée que ce soit
ma seule intervention éco conso réfère à
cela voilà pourquoi s'en tienne c'est
pour ça que je vous apporte cette
clarification donc à ma connaissance en
tout cas ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui
serait chargée de la dlep de la défense
est ce qu'on a demandé à l'état français
d'intervenir ou pas du tout et peut-être
de demander son transfèrement
voilà les alertes et d'abord de la
situation c'est bien légitime
j'aurais pu alerter donc aux lions
étaient c'est normal sur deux de faire
et ensuite au niveau à marrakech le
consulat il ya eu un soutien consulaire
absolument remarquable il a été deux
fois deux fois en prison
il songe et voilà où là on a aidé à
faire en sorte que la soeur de brahim
puisse aussi se dépasser et voyager
jusqu'au maroc
vous imaginez la difficulté par 72
points des bidons qu'ils ont été
absolument présent ensuite se posera
éventuellement la question du
transfèrement mais c'est ça mais qui ne
peut intervenir c'est à dire donc de
l'exécution de la peine en france dans
des conditions où la peine se
substituerait à peine français se
situerait donc bien sûr à la semaine
marocaine chose sauf qu'il faut que la
peine prononcée soit définitive donc il
faut attendre pour l'instant on a fait
appel à nous faut attendre les trois
semaines là comme vous avez dit il faut
attendre l'arrêt de l'arrêt d'appel
parce que vous avez ce poids qui sortent
dans trois semaines
bah oui mais j'ai bien sûr j'ai nommé
jeux géants quoi qu'il arrive à celle de
la volonté je me bats pour qu'il sorte
donc là quoi qu'il arrive ils vont
passer donc trois semaines en prison
encore nous ont fait une demande qui a
examiné lundi
il ya une possibilité qu'il sorte
d'accorder un système au maroc de
liberté sous caution
d'accord la qui existe aussi en france
vous avez des nations donc voilà en
cause ça sera ça sera examinée ont fait
en fait tout notre possible pour qu'ils
sortent dès lundi quitte à être jugé à
devoir rester au maroc et à être jugé
dans le dos n'est d'après de pense
forcément à sa famille vous avez des
nouvelles de sa famille parce qu'un nom
se mérite pour l'or d'abord ils sont
absolument remarquable de dignité et de
dévouement à voir ce qu'il faut faire
je peux vous dire qu'il faut en faire
où ai je tiens à dire dans ce délire des
réseaux sociaux que la famille de brahim
fait l'objet de menaces de mort et jeudi
qui a comme un fossé entre un mauvais
délire mais c'est un mauvais des gens de
petits mâles et déjà jeunesse sur
l'intégrité physique de brahim de samy
et de 2h03 troisième ami de leur
entourage familial et de leur entourage
professionnel donc là je dis stop ça
suffit que c'est que ces personnes
d'abord tous ceux qui jugent qu'ils
condamnent qui vous guette greffer des
querelles anciennes sur sur leurs choses
sur ce sursaut sur cet événement d'abord
fast leur examen de conscience
ou peut-être un effort de mémoire sur
qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient à 24 25 ans
entre copains en ayant bu un coup ce
genre de pitreries de dénis ranque la
seule chose c'est de là que ça a été
filmé que ça a été diffusée mais qui
regarde ce qu'ils ont fait aujourd'hui
de dire qu'on a qu'on a pu faire
bien sûr que là il s'agit il y avait une
intention comique c'est raté c'est raté
complètement raté les faits que je
comprends qu'ils aient des marots dix
ont été blessés
simplement ils peuvent être que blessé
pas bien sûr bien sûr mais il faut c'est
un scandale
voilà faut aussi les marocains sont des
gens intelligents
bien sûr que paris se régale passion et
est rarement ami avec la raison je pense
que sur cette journée de la terre voilà
qu'on aime et qu'on sera un peu on est
de rendre la fraternité j'espère pour
vous que lundi vous aurez des bonnes
nouvelles
en tout cas j'ai on suivra la sphère
lundi